Melbourne we're actually leaving
Melbourne now we are on our way to the
wine regions of Victoria toriel goodbye
to the city we are now in part two of
the three part series where the work is
hungry boy until today we're thirsty
boys taking on odd today on working wine
Australia Edition we're gonna be trying
three bottles of wine at three
drastically different price points to
find out which wine is the most worth it
at its price so I did some more
independent research about Australian
drinking culture I learned from our
driver Sam in alternatives you sing
Cheers
this one is a little bit more of a
thinker up yours I thought a thinker
it's a stinker
my name is Alistair per brick on the
fourth generation winemaker we're
standing in the to bilk winery which
began its operations back in 1860 today
we're going to be talking about my son
and in particular 2016 vintage we have a
hundred acres which is the largest
single holding in the world we make our
most in that it is stainless steel
fermented the critical factor is about
excluding oxygen over every step of the
process that's the only way you'll be
able to showcase the diversity and
flavors that the variety has the wine
enters the bottle and the guests cover
and then it just runs around gets
labeled into boxes stacked away ready
for sale in the case over there we saw a
spectrum of marcin's that are getting
darker as the bottle is an older can
tell us what is happening with those
that's just the normal oxidative process
more yellow closer it is to its best as
admitted a mature wine tasters what
should we be looking out for the best
way for you to develop your pellets is
to drink a lot of water so you got a
very happy future in front of yourself
we're starting off with the 2016 Marcin
from the number one Marcin supplier in
the world pale white wines are one of
the most beautiful colors in the natural
world to smell you have to smell wine
before you drink it I haven't seasoned
wine tave you want what helps
clogged up your glasses seasoned my
whatever
honestly Halloween candy it's like
starbursts
and Snickers tell me what you smell I'm
like a pig in a nap at the beach right
guys coming by with the cart of fruit
pineapple and the oranges and the citrus
fruits my drink whoo I pick up a wine
that's this color I'm expecting
sharpness so this is extremely smooth
words that come to mind sweet oddly very
complex complex leaf ooh yeah there's
something fun about tasting wine where
it's made I mean we're in this cool old
building don't look like you're tasting
history the environment sure I'm gonna
get you a new glass we were encouraged
to actually try the marce on what it was
like in 2010 in 2010 there were grapes
at work
that turned into this all just a baby
how old are you
alrighty I'm Travel 2010 here we go
smell it
Jesus have you learned to nothing whoa
that is a drastically different smell
this is sure nice its musky err know
what this makes me think of you're a kid
put a rubber band in your mouth if you
reduced all of the acridness and just
had that pure taste your bottle with
that rubber band it's like a little pine
it like pine Coney I bet a rubber tree
smells and tastes exactly like this one
in a delicious way I know that sounds
crazy it's not crazy do you Adam come
here was that wrong thank you
mellow routine delight of a wine and
there is a problem look properly
slightly bubbly wine fat grapes native
to Australia are not suitable for wine
really the wine industry in Australia
actually comes from immigrants from
Europe those people then exported back
here transcontinental train at its
finest Wow it was an interesting wine
fact way do you want to hear more about
that back is more not really my name's
Ian faith I'm the chief storyteller here
at pals wine what does that mean exactly
it means that I have absolutely no
qualifications whatsoever that I have
not a wine maker I'm not a bit of
culture with I just love wine and I love
talking about line today we're gonna be
trying the ladies of chic their lunch
dressed ladies with their lunch is there
a story behind that there is a story
about that now chief winemaker was an
avid hunter he was eating these meats
and trying to match the right wine to it
and thought there's got to be a wine
that's perfect for game food what
specific foods did you have
so at the moment we're matching a
venison with the Shiraz we a picture of
radish you get this wonderful burst of
flavor between the two that best
complement each other really well
Bauer's wine is located in the Stratford
ranges is a cool climate region now
vineyards are at 500 metres above sea
level it's a very even ripening process
so you get really great right fruit but
you maintain some really lovely acid
with the lime and that's because of the
weather you have in this particular area
solutely because of that cool apartment
the fruit has time to develop these
really intense flavors we fermented in
stainless steel to start off with may
retain half of that back in stainless
steel so heat that primary fruit
character 25% of the back yo into very
traditional oak barrels so you do get a
lot of new oak flavor coming in vegan
last 25% we put in two hundred and forty
year old English car those three
components have been blended back
together to create the final wine
there's some impressive chemistry
happening there should we trust them
[Music]
I can only start this taste test I just
left thank you why because it's the most
romantic setting possible hope your
glasses of wine of that gets let's just
take a moment and appreciate this
alright do the boys who drink their
lunch that's delightful that's gorgeous
little speechless right now by just the
wine the countryside and the baby over
there hanging out with us what sort of
mouth movement should I do and tasting a
wine for the first time yeah
let's taste our wine for real this time
[Music]
that's like a whole other why ok I got
exactly what that tastes like now it's
fruity it dances on your tongue it
actually makes you thirsty or the more
you drink up yours this is a dangerous
wine wine is often regarded as a
pretentious beverage something he knows
what I'm talking about something that's
enjoyed in lounges but this is in fact
the proper setting for wine to be
enjoyed it's not for dark dining rooms
it's for bright crisp vistas and the
alcohol is indefinitely there I can tell
you that right now cuz I'm feeling great
so here we have venison deer for the
uninitiated with a little beetroot shut
me out
[Music]
damn good no oh man that's beautiful oh
I love this it makes wine seem a little
bit more rugged and connected to the
earth in a way that I've never
appreciated before this countryside is a
wonderland kind of have a crush on this
lady the boys who drink their lunch wine
back Australia actually exports more
wine to the UK than France does really
yeah
Australians seem like they would share
anything with anybody we made a bunch of
wine come come have it the French on the
other hand seem like oh I just keep it
in my sent off no one drinks it forever
hey look some pals sheep hold out Steven
loves sheep oh my phone
womp womp
[Music]
my name's Nick I'm a winemaker at also
interstate and one of the owners along
with my two assistants today we're
tasting the music musk adele and museum
musket which are both fortified wines on
average 100 years old fortified wine is
a wine that's fortified by spirit you
know case neutral great spirit so you're
adding the stronger alcohol to a wine
that's not done with becoming a wine
correct so grapes there on the vine
right into autumn where there's sugar
accumulation is super-high before the
yeast gobble up all sugar and turn algo
we pump in 96 percent grade spirit which
stops the yeast in their tracks
increases the alcohol talked about 18
percent and fortifies the line so the
wines were tasting today our blend of
different years but on average it's 100
years old you're actually inheriting
somebody who had the foresight to barrel
up the wine and let it sit for 100 years
yeah that's right are you presently
creating wine that 100 years in the
future then also turn into this wine
that's not kind of a weird thing to
think about isn't it is yeah it's a one
that no one will drink whilst I'm alive
how do you arrive at the combination of
wines that go into this to form the
blend so there might be in 30 or 40
wines law and uh please smell and taste
through the ones and choose the final
blend such an amazing complex style of
wine once it goes a long way so how much
is this wine about a thousand dollars is
a lot of money I know my sisters and I
actually asked our accountant if he
could work out what the wine costs us to
make he came back with a figure of
twenty thousand dollars a bottle really
why by adding up all the time it's taken
to look after the wine and my sisters
and I said we can't charge that that's a
thousand dollars should cover our costs
and yeah imagine a twenty thousand
dollar new car that you could have for a
thousand dollars yeah we're going to now
try and who $1,000 wines this one is the
old sense museum mosquito mosket Del's
more aromatic entice a bit larvae
I've never experienced that much wine if
I just stepping at first it reminded me
of when I discovered my mother's vanilla
extract and I was like this will be
delicious let me set the scene you're in
Harry Potter's rural okay can you walk
into a chocolate candy shop yeah and
there's just all these ridiculously
amazing candy on the wall this would for
sure be Dumbledore his preferred drink
here oh my god that's extremely tasty I
don't want to sound pretentious like it
was the deepest richest grapey raisin
flavor just so raising it's like you had
the most delicious banquet dinner the
moment after your last bite and you're
reminded of all of the flavors you just
had it's all of those in an instant and
it has the touch of a lover I kind of
get what you mean yes yes this one is
the old science museum must get two
richer and more concentrated into say it
to be sweeter whoa this is a step up
from the previous one is it deep couch
steaming you made your glass with the
smelling you're a monster
that one was more fragrant this one's
more intense it's like this labyrinth of
flavors that is why it would be double
doors favorite drink you know when he
pulls the memories out of his mind this
is like that
Time Warp where you can just sample an
infinite number of memories taking the
top of the room of my mouth but I don't
have paste buds out there how's that
possible
I'm having a hard time coming up with
the words to describe how powerful and
beautiful this is I think that's
important if it was easier to explain it
wouldn't be as worth it somebody was
preparing this wine before I was alive
if my mom was alive but they didn't know
that it would make this and that is the
crazy part I'm still not sure I know
totally what it tastes like but it
tastes like a lot and I'm liking it
which wine was the most worth its price
for you the Mar sonnet - bill it's
unlike any other white wine I've ever
had bowels the ladies who shoot their
lunch that was my work at winter of
course that may be on the bottle gotcha
did she say pin my heart perhaps it was
just the most delicious and I really
like the label and to be honest that's
how I pick most of my line who's your
winner they were just all so good I
think I'm gonna go with all same wine
really yes I can't believe it
I'm not a fancy boy I promise that wine
was born more than a hundred years ago
even reduce the history that does it for
worth it wine all the dishes what's your
favorite wine I win this is only part
two of a three part series so we've got
something special coming up maybe it's
in the background of the shot actually
rhymes with break because we're raking
in the cow rhymes with okay
it's not cake though oh yes